alain le vern donc vient d'être élu
président du conseil régional il est un
proche de laurent fabius thierry bercot
nous prose nombreuses parts dont le
portrait de cet homme qui a gravi toutes
les étapes de la vie politique avant
cette élection d'aujourd'hui alain le
vern a été pendant longtemps enseignant
avant de se lancer en politique en 1981
mitterrand devient président de la
république et lui est nommé premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste en
seine-maritime poste qu'il occupe
jusqu'à l'année dernière puis en 1984 il
devient membre du bureau national et du
comité directeur du ps proche de laurent
fabius il va gravir également tous les
échelons au niveau local en 1983 il est
élu maire adjoint de petit quevilly
puis en 1989 il conquiert un chef rural
la mairie de saint saëns qu'il dirige
toujours et dont il est député depuis
alain le vern est également conseiller
régional depuis 1986 et il était la tête
de liste de la majorité plurielle pour
ces élections régionales
ailleurs c'est un langage est également
un passionné de vélo et il a été
plusieurs fois champion de france des
élus